the name on my book has sex drugs and
rock and roll
the rise of America's 1960s
counterculture my book focuses on kind
of the whole of American Bohemia to a
certain extent so I go back and talk
about early progenitors I talk about
figures like Edgar Allen Poe and Walt
Whitman I talk about members of the
lyrical left in the early 20th century
John Reed Louise Bryant I talked about
the hipsters and then I focus on the
beats I get two figures of the cast of
Allen Ginsberg and Jack Kerouac who are
toward the central biographical elements
in this book and then I go on and talk
about Timothy Leary Ken Kesey and then a
whole array of characters who course
through the decade of the 1960s when we
think of the counterculture of the 1960s
when we think of the hippies we think of
literally millions of participants in
one capacity or another and they were
individuals who were disenchanted with
matters as they were in some fashion
they were concerned about the greatest
stain on the American body Republic Jim
Crow its continuance they were deeply
concerned about the war in Vietnam so
those are kind of two of the twin
pillars in a manner of speaking but they
were also concerned about elemental
issues they were concerned about family
relationships and personal dealings and
sexuality and consciousness and
rationality and there was this
coalescing of forces some demographics
and economic some literary some cultural
some political in nature that melded
together and provided this kind of back
draw that allowed for the counterculture
of the 1960s to be as large and scope
and scale as it proved to be there were
several sparks or triggers for the
counterculture of the 1960s I think you
have the backdrop of the Cold War
internationally speaking and
domestically unfolding simultaneously I
think you had that feeling and that
reality of alienation that I referred to
earlier I think the demographic matters
came into play too you have these large
pools of young people congregating
together often on or near college
university campuses and then you had
those terrible realities of the terrible
realities of racism and war and I think
that enabled a large number of young
people to be receptive to different
possibilities and then you had these key
figures like Ginsberg and Kerouac and
Leary and Kesey but you also had the the
great bands of the era you know and the
great musicians of a more solitary cast
you know from Bob Dylan to the Beatles
to the San Francisco sound groups
airplane Quicksilver Grateful Dead and
so forth and I think that young people
were were drawn to messages that were
being imparted messages of a challenging
of a probing of a provocative cast and
sometimes of a of a radical nature
contesting the verities that were in
place contesting American institutions
and even contesting the way people
interacted with one another the way
people fought and the way they behaved
there's a very radical
facet of the counterculture that I that
I highlight there were revolutionary
possibilities
I think inherent in some of this which
is why it's perceived to be as dangerous
as it was considered by some of the
powers that were and it was treated
accordingly there are other avenues
there's the setting up of an underground
press syndicate so underground
newspapers cropped up there's new kind
of comics that are in in place during
the spear we think of Robert Crumb and
and Gilbert Shelton and others the rag
is the underground newspaper in in
Austin in the 1960s and I and I talk
about it again in that chapter on that
Texas capital city and it was and this
incredible compendium that publication
was I mean it you can go back and look
at the issues and you can get these
snapshot looks of so much that was going
on these w the counterculture but the
other movements of the of the entire
period really interesting matter to
reflect on and I grappled with this as
best I can in the book is the question
of how Universal and scope and nature
the counterculture proved to be because
we think of the counterculture we think
of Greenwich Village in New York City we
think of Haight Ashbury in San Francisco
we think of other pockets Venice you
know above LA and so forth but the
reality is where young people could
congregate you could find seeds for and
then the planting of the counterculture
which means virtually any college
university had the possibilities
inherent in the fact that there was a
community of like-minded people that
would be
present so for instance one of the focal
points in one of the chapters is on
Austin Texas the University of Texas and
people would kind of question why that
would be included but Austin and the
University of Texas were epicenters in
their own fashion for the new left for
the anti-war movement for the
counterculture for the women's movement
so I used that as kind of a microcosmic
examining process just as I focus on
hate not surprisingly when you get into
1967 earlier in scope you can talk about
the appearance at Columbia University of
the small circle of friends that was
referred to in that matter was Ginsberg
and Kerouac and their buddies who were
challenging the institution that was
Columbia and they were challenging the
literary establishment and they were
questioning Moloch as Ginsburg referred
to it as he does in his famous epic poem
howl as Kerouac doesn't on the road so
the delivery of howl which was presented
in public for the first time in 1955 the
publication of on the road two years
later those are a couple of those
seminal moments and they serve as
triggers the appearance the emergence of
the psilocybin project at Harvard
Believe It or Not which involved Timothy
Leary and then eventually Richard Alpert
and brought in young people to serve as
kind of guinea pigs as it were and
proved to be enormous ly controversial
surprisingly what became most
controversial for the August institution
that was Harvard was the fact that
undergraduates were included in the mix
it seemed to be okay if it worked
immunity members professors or graduate
students but where Harvard drew the line
was with undergraduates to Merry
Pranksters their journey across America
in the summer of 1964 they went to meet
Kerouac in New York City it was not a
happy experience
Kerouac had shifted very far to the
political right by that point in time
they went to meet the Leary and Alpert
at Millbrook estate above New York City
and that was not a happy experience
either Leary in fact didn't even greet
the pranksters even though if they had
gone 3,000 miles for that encounter to
take place you get later into the the
1960s the mid-60s in the latter portion
of it altogether and it's almost like
there's one event after another there
are the anti-war protests in Berkeley
and Oakland and in the Bay Area in
general that involved Ginsberg and the
pranksters and the Hells Angels there
are the acid test that the pranksters
put on 66-67 there's the human being and
be in in San Francisco Golden Gate Park
in January of 1967
there's the Summer of Love in 1967
there's there's Woodstock there's
Altamont
there's the unveiling of the the family
the killings by Charles Manson's gang in
late 1969 so again it's it's almost as
if there were these ethical points that
eventuated and some spoke to the better
side or the angelic angelic qualities
contained within the counterculture some
spoke to the darker side and you end up
with people's own
frailties and their own weaknesses and
the despoil Asian that drug usage brings
about and all the sexually transmitted
diseases that are rusher din and and
then the lost lives that are such a part
of the story and you know it's we think
of the successes but there are those who
burned out along the way I mean they're
the famous musicians right who who died
because of drug overuse correct so you
think of and you know almost in one fell
swoop
when Janice and Jimmy and Jim died Janis
Joplin and Jimi Hendrix and Jim Morrison
in a matter of months 70 and 71 but
there are countless lesser-known figures
who they're you know education became
stunted and their Occupational
possibilities became wanted stillborn
and some of the people never recovered
they never recovered you know their
minds didn't recover and their psyches
didn't recover in their damaged
relationships were not we knitted so
there's you know lots of serious aspects
to the to the counterculture and some as
I said before you know seemingly were of
this millennial possible possibility
wise are set some of them seemingly
reached to the Stars right in a
millennial light manner but in some ways
it was the apocalyptic realities that
helped to dampen the hopes of how
transformative this might have been
I talked about this at the the near
close of the book the computer
revolution that we've experienced over
the last few decades the PC revolution
Silicon Valley at all a lot of that is
believe it or not connected with the
counterculture and part of it is
pertaining to who was drawn to those
kinds of pursuits and the the attempt to
reach a different kind of consciousness
in different ways and just as the US
intelligence agencies in the US military
helped to spawn the counterculture
believe it or not through drug test that
people like Ken Kesey partook enough and
then helped to spread the gospel about
the military is heavily involved in
birthing the computer revolution of the
1970s and beyond so there's this weird
kind of symbiotic relationship between
the counterculture and the US military
and intelligence operatives and I'm not
saying that this is a conspiratorial in
nature I'm not suggesting that I'm what
I'm stating is the fact that there is
this twining of these threads and that's
one of the reason why the
countercultures impact has been as
enduring as it's been it's often been
viewed in a very character caricatured
manner
there have been cliches drawn about it
there have been stereotypes that have
been cast around it it's largely been
dismissed and denigrated and I think it
needs to be received and perceived for
the serious
cultural and potentially political force
that it was my argument is that this was
a radical unfolding with revolutionary
possibilities did the revolution play
out was certainly not in the manner that
had been hoped for by those who
participated in the counterculture I
think that's obviously the case but
again the impact nevertheless of the
counterculture was was huge and remains
so today